Elon Musk used to own plenty of real estate
in California.
But in 2020 he went on a huge selling spree,
parting ways with his multi-million dollar
properties one by one by one by one.
In total, he’s sold seven houses.
His eighth and only remaining home - a beautiful,
Bay area estate that he describes as a special
place - hit the market in June.
The price: $37.5 million.
Not long ago, Musk packed his bags and moved
to Texas - which, by the way, has no personal
income tax.
Whereas the Golden State imposes the highest
level of income tax on its richest residents.
There are plenty of fancy homes in
south Texas a half hours’ drive from Boca
Chica where SpaceX built its rocket facility
for Starship.
But the second richest person in the world
says instead, he’s chosen to rent a small
home from his company located by the production
site worth a mere $50,000.
He reportedly lives in a foldable house in
a box like this according to Teslarati.
The windows and walls unfold into a 400-square
foot space complete with a kitchen, bathroom,
bedroom, and living room.
They’re built by a startup called Boxabl
which had no comment about Musk’s living
situation when I reached out to them.
But the company has certainly been dropping
hints about a new customer.
In a promotional video from late 2020, Boxabl
showed off one of its units with a photo of
SpaceX’s Falcon 9 and had this
to say about a special delivery.
We just installed in Boca Chica, Texas for
a top-secret customer.
Pretty exciting to have these guys of our
initial customer.
The portable homes have a starting price of
$49,500 and are light enough to be towed by
a Model X which costs twice
as much.
By living on-site - Musk has 24/7 access to all of SpaceX’s developments as
it powers full steam ahead in the hopes of
sending humans to Mars.
Musk has famously signaled his commitment
to his companies by placing himself right
in the center of the action.
Like the times he sleeps at Tesla’s factories
which I talked about in another video.
Or further back, when he and his brother started
their first company, he slept at the office
and showered at the YMCA.
In this case - his vision of a factory line
of fully reusable launch vehicles supersedes
any desire for luxurious living.
Downsizing his house is a metaphor for downsizing
his life in order to focus on his ambitions.
And if making life multi-planetary weren’t
enough, he’s trying to solve traffic congestion
with the Boring Company, wants to make humans
smarter by implanting tiny wires with Neuralink,
and then of course there’s his electric
car company Tesla which has a Gigafactory
under construction in Austin.
His girlfriend Grimes confirmed she has also moved
to the Texas capital.
Musk is not the only billionaire to live frugally.
Facebook’s Mark Zuckerberg famously has
a wardrobe of simple, gray shirts.
One of the most successful investors of all time, Warren Buffet, often eats breakfast
at McDonald’s.
And still lives in the same house in Omaha
that he purchased in 1958 for $31,500.
Still, it’s nothing like a tiny home in
a box.
Musk has also been seen at another property
in Boca Chica village right next to SpaceX’s site.
The CEO has been spotted staying at this house
that SpaceX remodeled and is said to be one
of the nicest in the neighborhood.
It was appraised at $47,000 in 2020 and is
now worth more than three times that according
to the Wall Street Journal.
Real estate in Boca Chica has soared in value
since Musk appealed for people to move to
the area and said SpaceX would have thousands of job openings in the next few years.
Boca Chica is a tiny community.
There are only about 40 houses here with no shops, restaurants, or even water pipes.
Water is trucked in.
The people who live here are mostly retired
and come to spend the winters.
SpaceX has been offering to buy all the houses.
Some residents have taken the money while
others have refused and have complained of
bullying by SpaceX to try and get them to
sell.
South Texas is precious to SpaceX because
of its proximity to the equator which gives
rockets a boost in speed due to the rotation
of the Earth.
The company also has a long history in the
Lonestar state.
It’s had a rocket engine testing site north
of Austin for two decades.
SpaceX has hinted that it wants to develop
the Boca Chica area into a resort.
It posted a job for a resort development manager
in 2020.
Musk envisions a city called Starbase that
would incorporate the small community.
Boxabl has even pitched the idea of
more housing units for the expansion of Starbase.
As for this $50,000 humble abode?
Musk is unlikely to buy million-dollar digs
in the future.
He has said his plan is to not own a home.
Who needs one  when Mars is calling?
To call Musk a busy man is an understatement.
He reportedly plans his day in five-minute
slots in order to make the best use of his time.
If you’d like to learn how to be more productive
- maybe not on the scale of Musk but productive
nonetheless - my sponsor Skillshare can help
and you can try it out for FREE.
The first one is simply scheduling.
Author and video creator Thomas Frank helps
me organize and improve my workflow as I craft
my stories.
Skillshare can also help you get better at
making videos.
with classes on editing, creating animations,
and designing stand-out YouTube thumbnails.
There are thousands of inspiring classes broken
up into short lessons, there are no ads, and
it’s for all skill levels.
The first 1,000 people who use the link in
my description will receive a 1-month free
trial of Skillshare Premium.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.